extreme weather is becoming more
frequent and widespread around the
country California suffered its worst
wildfire season in history last year
remember that in January the Midwest saw
record-breaking cold and historic
flooding in Nebraska and just last month
caused more than a billion dollars in
damages that's billion with the beat CBS
News climate and weather contributor
that's Jeff Berra Delhi is here to show
us why changes in the Arctic are having
such a big impact here Jeff welcome good
morning guys and good morning everybody
we can trace the origins of some of the
recent extreme weather here to rapid
changes up north now normally the polar
ice caps keep the earth temperature down
by reflecting the sun's rays back into
space now the ice is melting fast listen
to this over 900,000 square miles nearly
six times the size of California in just
the past 40 years as a result more of
the sun's rays are being absorbed that
is heating the Arctic twice as fast as
the global average and that uneven
warming is now impacting the weather
here in the mid-latitudes by throwing
the jet stream out of whack the jet
stream is a river of air in the upper
atmosphere controlling the track of
storms and the distribution of cold and
warm air and recent evidence shows the
jet stream is becoming more amplified
making the weather more extreme that's a
theory but we're seeing it play out in
real time right now yeah people really
have to pay attention to this so we've
had two of the worst hurricane seasons
yes not recently
what role did climate change play in
that so you know we believe it or not
you're not gonna believe this snap we
are adding four Hiroshima atomic bombs
worth of energy to the ocean every
second every second that's how much heat
is being added to the oceans that comes
out and it manifests itself in the form
of extreme weather so a couple of things
that we want to talk about hurricane
Michael hurricane Maria hurricane
Michael has just upgraded to a category
five storm winds of 160 miles an hour we
do not yet have an attribution study on
that storm but what we do know is water
temperatures way above normal in the
Northeast Gulf some of that was natural
some could be climate change we saw a
rapid intensification of 50 miles an
hour
within 24 hours two
and fall there are studies that now show
that rapid intensification is in fact
increasing and has been increasing for
the past couple of decades and Hurricane
Maria with an atmosphere that can hold a
lot more moisture it's dumping a lot
more rain they're saying that it's three
times more likely to have a storm with a
magnitude of rainfall of Hurricane Maria
now than we had in the 1950s three times
more like a mother what are we supposed
to do with that information you hear it
and then you think what are we supposed
to do well the bottom line is there is
no masking tape solution we know the
answer the answer is we need to wean
ourselves off of fossil fuels you know a
lot of times you go to the doctor if
you're really sick the doctor says I'm
sorry there's nothing we can do for you
we know exactly what to do we just have
to have the willpower to do it get off
fossil fuels you'll be back with more
information
yeah we're the show's over thank you so
much Jeff thank you